ha viajado recientemente el año pasado
viaje a taiwán desierto quiero decir lo
recuerdo yo creo que te lo haya dicho ya
me estás confundiendo
te sientes nervioso un poco porque no
puedo verlas pero todo estará bien vamos
[Música]
crees que serás capaz de establecer una
conexión con alguien aunque no puedas
verlas bueno puedo intentarlo no prometo
nada ya veremos las hacemos pasar hagan
las pasar vamos
ashley eres la primera delante y toma
asiento
qué tal y como está cómo estás bien como
está estoy bien soy
dirty diana dirty diana si quiere sólo
estoy bromeando soy rebeca rpk ese es el
nombre de mi prima es algo incómodo cómo
te llamas hoy llevo irene disculpa estoy
muy nervioso está bien está bien
de dónde eres bueno soy de taiwán
dietéticas soy estudiante de enfermería
en la universidad viola y hace poco vi
la temporada completa de american war
stories para estar preparada así que
tomaste la decisión de tu carrera pasada
en américa en hogwarts tory si que haces
juego fútbol profesional en el condado
de orange soy estudiante de enfermería
muy bien me gusta eso sí y certificada
en rcp fantástico así que puedes robarme
el aliento solo esa forma de salir me
gusta jugar videojuegos soy una
escritora en ascenso y qué haces para
divertirte me gusta ir al gym jugar
fútbol salir con amigos
no sé qué más decir
y esto es muy difícil
todos parecen buenas personas lo siento
no es nada personal pero álex no sentí
ninguna conexión con ella
[Música]
essence
diría que rebecca es el nombre de mi
prima así que sería muy incómodo
vez ella quiso tomar el control en tan
poco tiempo sin alguna razón
[Música]
muy bien dime cómo sería tu cita ideal
puede que haciendo senderismo o algo en
la naturaleza honestamente algo
divertido para dejar de pensar y solo
pasarla bien probablemente con algo
interactivo como una sala de juegos bien
soy muy competitivo no me gusta ganar
pues vas a sentirte mal porque yo gano
todo el tiempo ganas todo el tiempo está
bien me gustaría ir a un lugar tranquilo
donde podamos conocernos y hablar como
en un campo pero corriendo un poco de
pollo frito pollo frito me gusta mucho
aquí restaurante iríamos sería feliz con
ir a mcdonald's fantástico corramos el
riesgo comencemos con mcdonald's y
después iríamos a
red lo que opinas del sushi comestible
sushi en mi cuerpo
estoy dispuesta a todo estás dispuesta a
todo qué comida te gusta vas a eliminar
me apenas lo escuches de esta ensalada
mi plato favorito es pasta te gusta la
pasta al dente la pasta de cocción no sé
qué pensar sobre eso
carmen no sé no me sentí conectado
[Música]
no me gustaron sus respuestas sobre su
cita ideal
demonios esto es muy difícil de hecho el
que deje pasar de cocción la pasta me
decepcionó
creo que has
lo siento
[Música]
diana qué es lo que más te decepciona
las personas que son de mente cerrada
alguien que sea muy engreído o que sea
egocéntrico y muy presumido muchas
personas me han dicho que soy muy
engreído eres engreído soy una persona
humilde pienso que algo que me
decepcionaría sería aquellas personas
que no prueban cosas nuevas mucho tu has
hecho algo nuevo he estado haciendo yoga
estuve en españa y londres hay quienes
pick english
[Música]
puedo enseñarte a camps en el desierto
hace poco bien eres muy valiente para
hacer eso me gusta mucho cocinar nuevas
recetas así que siempre busco curioso y
eso es lo único que veo en youtube solo
vídeos de cocina vídeos de cocina y
genial
diría que diana
[Música]
también jordan
no lo sé es una decisión muy difícil me
gustaban más las otras chicas
felicidades has llegado lejos
cuáles son tus metas tus sueños en el
futuro desde que soy estudiante de
enfermería quiero titularme como
enfermera el cáncer ha estado presente
en mi familia así que quiero orientarme
más hacia allá qué hay de ti bueno
pienso llevar esto del fútbol tan lejos
como pueda no los jueces a tu pasión
cielo al sueño con el fútbol alguna vez
te has despertado y golpeado algo por
accidente a veces tengo esos sueños en
los que me caigo te despiertas de
repente alguien viene hacia ti o te
estás cayendo o dios mío si bien ha
dejado
irene cuéntame sobre tus metas tengo
muchas
espero poder viajar en el futuro hemos
viajado recientemente el año pasado
logré viajar a taiwán cierto creo que lo
recuerdo mi culpa no creo que te lo haya
dicho ya me estás confundiendo alguien
más es de taiwán no tú no tú a pegarle
con la solución a massa
qué es lo que te gusta de yes es
estudiante de enfermería
tiene muchas cosas a su favor le gustan
las cosas nuevas a irene le gusta
cocinar me encanta una chica que sepa
cocinar y cuidar de sí misma me puedo
quedar con las dos podemos ser amigos
[Risas]
[Música]
hay que dar con irene
sin resentimientos
el agua
hablas con irene estoy hablando con
irene ahora mismo para empezar me gustó
que estuviera un poco de esto hoy lo
siento cuando me veas verás que todo
todo mi cuerpo está temblando no está
bien está bien pero eso quiere decir que
eres humana pero ese comentario de la
ensalada no te favoreció de profundis te
con otra chica eso tampoco te ayudó en
nada así que había tomado mis apuntes
les gustaría verse adelante
soy cada gusto
ya que se han visto están interesados en
tener una segunda cita sí claro sí sí
genial gracias gracias déjame guardar tu
números y claire
[Música]